bonsoir se souvenir de christian maes
qui vient juste d'arriver à paris c'est
évidemment le premier titre de
l'actualité de ce dimanche 16 avril
tient avec son compagnon suisse
christian maes a donc retrouvé ses
parents il ya quelques instants à roissy
ses parents et puis aussi comme vous le
voyez une foule de journalistes
philippe rochot fontaines ii était parmi
eux
mali vers cette main à libération a
effectivement lieu sans conditions
pourquoi libérer sans conditions si je
sais pourquoi je sais pourquoi je pense
que ma libération revient pour une très
très grande part au rôle joué par le
gouvernement nigérian dans cette affaire
et puis par le rôle joué par messieurs
les ambassadeurs de france et de suisse
ils sont eux-mêmes me chercher au bord
du lac
enfin parler demandé un niveau mondial
notre leur en irak ont permis de réguler
séparer de lui toujours avec lui de
revenir sur vos conditions de détention
à deux reprises les ravisseurs ont donc
un ananas et les ultimatums gouvernement
français oui est ce que vous sentez
menacés dans votre vie à ce moment là le
soir même du 5 février
on a passé une mauvaise nuit
effectivement mais après nous avons été
rassurés par ce qui nous gardaient et le
jour de tivat appartement du 20 février
nous étions jullion carta à midi et nous
étions parfaitement décontracté sachant
parfaitement qu'il n'y avait aucun
risque
il n'aurait pas qu'une étude cette
grande finale al assad à bord n'avait
pas du tout l'intention de le faire sur
place cette place de mort était
simplement un scénario
scénario de la prise d'otages voir
destinaire pour faire encore concept la
pression sont ils bien équipée bien
armés et bien disciplinée point de vue
civil sont bien sûr et s'organisent les
argents ai pas vu beaucoup
en laisse le temps
on possède quelques armes
mais plutôt des arcs et flèches de lance
des sacs à l'approché du tchad saviez
que c'était une zone d'insécurité ne
savait pas sinon je ne serais sûrement
pas aventuré par n'a aucun doute là
dessus
au bord du lac j'étais à l'institut de
recherche manou pas terrible j'ai
consulté une carte française est un pays
à une dizaine d'années j'ai pas de
problème j'ai été capturé et détenu
constamment en territoire tchadien
en tenant compte d'une certaine marge
d'erreur est ce que c'est que ma mère
aimerait dire quelque chose je crois je
voudrais dire quelque chose et je
voudrais que que tout le monde entende
je voudrais dire que je suis tu je suis
tout à ma joie mais en ce moment de joie
jeu je ne peux m'empêcher de penser aux
familles aux parents familles françaises
qui continuent de vivre dans l'angoissé
parce que l'un des leurs est retenu
prisonnier otage par portés disparus
quelque part dans le monde et ceci pour
des raisons arbitraires
je voudrais lancer un appel à tous ceux
qui m'écoutent pour que l'on puisse
faire une action commune à un niveau
international pour que l'on brise le mur
de silence qui les entoure et qu'on
puisse obtenir d'abord qu'ils soient
traités humainement et ensuite qu'il
soit très vite libéré dans ce journal
également victor vraiment de rome nous
parlera de la condamnation à mort d'aldo
moro par les brigades rouges
jacques sébille de washington nous
expliquera pourquoi jimmy carter a réuni
autour de lui ses proches collaborateurs
à camp david
philippe gassot dans le ciel nous
permettra d'assister à une grande
première le ravitaillement en vol un
mirage f1 ajoutez à ce tiercé
les résultats du vrai dire c'est le
bruit la télévision à longchamp quatre
vingt dix douce et puis cette toute
dernière nouvelle la mort à madagascar
de l'ancien président malgache philibert
tsiranana mort à l'âge de 68 ans
le détail maintenant de tous ses titres
commençons par la démocratie chrétienne
a demandé aujourd'hui que tous les
moyens licites et juridiquement possible
soit employé pour sauver la vie d'aldo
monde vous savez que dans le sixième
communiqué diffusé par les médias de
rouge hier soir le président de la
démocratie chrétienne a été condamné à
mort par les extrémistes un communiqué
qui a bien évidemment créé une vive
inquiétude en italie et en ramant
conseil de guerre à la démocratie
chrétienne aujourd'hui à rome après le
sixième message des brigades rouges tous
les dirigeants démocrates chrétiens sont
bouleversés avec en plus un sentiment
très laid d'impuissance peut-être n'y
at-il plus qu'à attendre le septième
message des brigades rouges qui
annoncerait l'exécution d'aldo moro dans
une prison du peuple à moins qu'il ne
s'agisse d'un coup de téléphone anonyme
qui précisera un journal ou une agence
de presse
l'endroit où était déposé le corps
d'aldo moro paraît maintenant que la
démocratie chrétienne serait disposé à
négocier la libération d'aldo moro meslé
prague tardif tout d'abord dans leurs
derniers messages les brigades rouges
disent que aldo moro a été condamné à
mort que c'est irrémédiable que c'est
définitif ensuite dans leurs précédents
messages
les brigades rouges n'ont jamais demandé
la libération de terroristes qui sont
actuellement en prison alors on peut se
demander sur quelle base on est ce faire
la négociation entre les terroristes et
la démocratie chrétienne
sur quelles bases pointe ont bien
négocié et avec qui
car apparemment aucun contact n'a été
établi avec les brigades rouges giovanni
calo né le secrétaire adjoint de la
démocratie chrétienne n'a rien pu dire
de précis
ap le conseil de guerre démocrate
chrétien il faudrait l'accord des autres
partis politiques
on peut envisager quelque chose sur le
plan international
tout cela paraît bien ni réelle
poly'sons le dernier message des
brigades rouges l'exécution d'aldo moro
ne constitue qu'une étape
oui seulement une étape il faut étendre
d intensifier les attaques contre l'état
impérialiste des multinationales
voilà qui ne laisse pas beaucoup de
place à l'espoir depuis hier
depuis que les brigades rouges
l'annoncé calme auront été condamné à
mort les centaines de personnes se sont
attroupées via mario fanny là ont été
tués les cinq gardes du corps d'aldo
moro
c'est une protestation silencieuse mais
tout le monde semble attendre ou
l'irrémédiable oui décidément il ya peu
de place ce soir pour les spéculations
sur le désir de la démocratie chrétienne
de négocier ou sur la possibilité pour
les brigades rouges de revenir sur leur
décision annoncée avec tant de
détermination et de publicité quand
david qu'on a vite c'est la résidence du
président américain situé à une centaine
de kilomètres washington la capitale de
coutume le numéro un américain reçoit
ses hôtes étrangers
cette fois aujourd'hui et demain ce sont
ses proches collaborateurs que le
président carter a convoqué en séminaire
à camp david
une façon comme une autre de marquer le
caractère exceptionnel de ces deux jours
de réflexion
cela paraît nécessaire au président
carter car il semble reconnaître comme
beaucoup quel quelque chose ne tourne
pas rond dans son administration jacques
c qui assez à camp david carter va
demander à son équipe de resserrer les
rangs ne dit on pas que certains
fonctionnaires
à l'intérieur de cette maison blanche
sont déçus désappointé par la politique
de leur administration
carter devra particulièrement préciser
les rôles de monsieur vance et de
monsieur brzezinski qui ont des
approches différentes en ce qui concerne
la politique étrangère car père devra
conforter son ministre des finances
monsieur blumentahl totalement
désappointé depuis qu'il a appris que
monsieur strauss avait été nommé
monsieur anti inflation par le président
carter sans que ces derniers en est
vraiment informé monsieur nouvelle table
le mot crise n'est pas le terme qui
convient exactement pour qualifier ce
qui se passe ici
mais les derniers sondages qui ont une
nouvelle fois la crise de confiance du
pays à l'égard de son président et
carter s'est d'autre part que déjà on
pense à sa succession un quotidien du
matin a cru bon de révéler que tête quel
est le troisième de la famille serais
peut-être candidat en 1980 c'est-à-dire
dans un peu plus de deux ans et demi
spéculation précipitation autant
d'éléments qui doivent inciter le
président carter a réajusté ses
objectifs et sa politique
je vous le disais en début de ce journal
nous tendent à prendre donc la mort du
président malgache de l'ancien président
malgache philibert tsiranana il avait 68
ans il est mort à l'hôpital cet après
midi c'est la radio qui l'annoncé douze
années au pouvoir et six années en
résidence surveillée c'est la carrière
politique de cet homme le président
tsiranana mis en échec par celui à qui
il avait confié les pleins pouvoirs le
général ramanantsoa en 1972 depuis les
élections il se considérait qu'on excuse
mais dans son propre pays lui-même ne
l'aurait jamais ce poisson très prisé en
sachet du sud cet été c'est de pêcher un
président
ah oui il ya une lutte terrible sur les
parquets midi voulez vous dire
bon ben on a voulu mais là c'est
mélanger au fouet là-bas à l'alto ce
petit réseau le même panier
je suis poitiers gère l'eau voilà tous
les abonnements vous signaler que cette
interview du président tsiranana
quelques quelques années avant sa mort
avait été réalisé par andré blanchet
manifestation en union soviétique c'est
assez rare pour être notée manifestation
plus précisément dans une des
républiques de l'union à savoir la
géorgie des dizaines de milliers de
personnes auraient défilé dans les rues
de tbilissi la capitale pour protester
contre la suppression du géorgien comme
langue nationale est là dans la nouvelle
constitution
sa formation qui demande évidemment une
confirmation
pas de problème en revanche pour la
manifestation qui s'est déroulée hier
soir à tel-aviv elle a bien eu lieu
puisque en voici les images
plusieurs dizaines de milliers de
personnes ont défilé à l'appel du
mouvement pour la paix dans la sécurité
s'agit là de soutenir la politique
étrangère du gouvernement béji et
surtout de réagir contre la
manifestation anti begin qui avait eu
lieu le 1er avril dernier à tel aviv
la situation militaire de la france n'a
évidemment rien à voir avec celle
d'israël
mais vous savez qu'il est nécessaire de
temps à autre de d'hésiter disons nos
capacités de défense et de défense
aérienne en particulier récemment sur
l'ensemble du territoire
presque tous les appareils de combat
français ont été engagés dans un
exercice qui portait le nom de code
datex 78 n'y avait pas des avions
français d'ailleurs les etats-unis la
grande-bretagne le canada l'allemagne
fédérale entre autres ont participé à
cet exercice
ce que je vous propose maintenant c'est
un reportage c'est exceptionnel pour la
première fois philippe gassot et à l'ins
ont pu filmer en vol le ravitaillement
des mirages f1 regardez bien
juste le temps d'enfiler votre
combinaison et votre casque vous allez
assister à cette première en vol comme
si vous
nous allons décoller dans quelques
minutes pour refus tu es une mission de
tenue d' alerte en vol grâce
ravitaillement en vol pour la première
fois dans la défense aérienne et sur
mirage f1
nous allons tenir un créneau d'alert
envol de 6h à quatre avions à quatre
mirage f1 alessio de la défense aérienne
et précisées par décret surveiller
l'espace aérien détecter et évaluer
toute menace et mettre toutes les
chances de son côté c'est réduire le
plus possible de 8 ans nous pouvons
estimer que le gagnant au minimum cinq
minutes c'est à dire plusieurs centaines
de kilomètres sur la réalisation de
l'interception
pour apporter les premières images des
f1 ravitaillement une solution mettre sa
tenue contigent est monté très haut
s'en remettre aux radars pour le parfum
qu'elle rendait nu et se défier
le travail de gardien du ciel même en
temps de paix n'est pas une petite
affaire 500000 avions parcourent le ciel
de france tous les ans et dans cette
masse une cinquantaine ne sont pas
identifiés faut donc trier reconnaître
et le cas échéant contraindre à
l'atterrisage le rendez-vous
ravitaillement se situe bien au-delà des
nuages après une mission d'intervention
dans les aiguilles cadrans bas en
cirrhose elle commence à baisser
rester en l'air bête la zone critique
évite bien entendu un retour à la base
un atterrissage et à redécoller une
importante est connu de temps cela
nécessite la part des pilotes à
l'entraînement extrêmement soucieuse à
très haute altitude il faut parvenir à
placer la crosse de remplissage d'un
mirage f1 au centre d'un panier qui se
promènent au bout d'un tuyau arriver à
la bonne vitesse à la bonne altitude
fille geste les réservoirs se
remplissent à la cadence d'une tonne à
la mine ans allongé dans la queue de
l'appareil le boomer c'est son nom qui
de les chasseurs il est prêt la main sur
la poignée interrompt
ravitaillement dans le cas où le tuyau
serait emporté par un avion
auxerre
dans le c 135 tout l'équipage est
harnaché de miles west parachute et
masque à oxygène danger la rupture des
tuyaux la pulvérisation du kérosène qui
pourraient s'enflammer au contact des
réacteurs ou l'iaaf
ensuite nous avions 80 tonnes de
carburant en france à 880 celles
habituellement voilée 8 ans et plus
le point de rendez vous est contrôlé en
permanence
l'aigle espoir que ces manoeuvres
resteront des
exercice l'opération avitaillement
veulent est terminée ou préférable
maintenant si l'on est ennemie d'éviter
les chasseurs et de ne pas rester dans
le collimateur
à la mission accomplie gayssot et à
l'insa ont pu réaliser ce reportage
grâce aux appareils de la base d'orange
d'istres la politique maintenant trois
petites phrases ce dimanche andré
bergeron de force ouvrière les patrons
doivent renoncer à utiliser la crise
comme alibi pour s'opposer à tout jean
colpin secrétaire du comité central du
parti communiste est responsable de la
du secteur entreprise pas un communiste
n'a exprimé de doute sur le fait que
notre parti ne porte aucune
responsabilité dans l'échec de la gauche
il y à un accord profond avec la
politique du parti
déclaration également de michel de wake
y participer ce soir au club de la
presse d'eurofins serrer les rangs
soutenir le gouvernement pour le rpr on
ne peut pas dire avant donc des idées
essentielles at il dit en substance
je ne voyais a laissé entendre que le
rpr voteraient la question de confiance
si monsieur raymond barre décidé de la
pause et mercredi je pense daniel wam
que ces petites phrases n'ont pas
troublé le premier ministre qui est
resté à paris ce week-end pour
travailler oui en effet loin de
l'agitation qu'il déteste le premier
ministre s'est barricadé à l'hôtel
matignon durant tout le week-end il a
ébauché derrière ses hauts murs le
discours de politique générale sur
lequel il demandera la confiance il a
compulsé les innombrables note préparée
par ses collaborateurs
mathieu par des rats mercredi au moins
sont tous les cadrans de l'économie
après deux ans d'efforts il évoquera
aussi tout ce qui reste à faire dans sa
déclaration d'environ trois quarts
d'heure rédigé dans son bureau qui donne
sur le parc
le chef du gouvernement fixera le cadre
de son action les intentions annoncées
seront concrétisés au fil des jours par
des décrets et des projets de vous tous
ces textes s'inspireront de trois
objectifs d
fini par le président de la république
poursuite du redressement plus grande
justice sociale et accroissement des
responsabilités des français c'est à
dire moins de pouvoirs pour
l'administration alors l'exposé du
premier ministre prendra fin ce taux la
forme d'une sorte de contrat de progrès
proposer au pays
monsieur var espère le programme commun
qui est l affiche que son propre projet
deviendra le pivot d'un débat national
alors si sur le plan économique la
situation reste difficile ils ont
comment est ce que ça représente sur le
plan politique est bien le premier
ministre sur ce plan là à la fois libre
le cheval n'est plus obstrué par des
élections importantes via les cantonales
et ce ne sont pas des avions aussi un
montant précis par ailleurs la majorité
malgré les réserves morales du rpr votre
à la confiance comme du reste le
souhaitent ces secteurs quant à
l'opposition elle est occupée à
débrouiller l'écheveau de ses propres
problèmes internes et du côté des
syndicats
malgré des prédictions d'avant les
élections et bien le climat est plutôt
une sorte d'armistice à malaga alors
monsieur bart mettra-t-il pour autant
les bouchées doubles bien nous serons
bientôt quatre rubriques accident
particulièrement chargé ce week-end sur
la route d'abord pour la première fois
en 12 ans un camion a brûlé sous le
tunnel du mont blanc
un incendie qui aurait pu être
dramatique le chauffeur a quand même pu
sauver et alerté les pompiers sont vite
mis une heure pour maîtriser les flammes
en montagne le sauvetage des cinq
alpinistes parisiens qui étaient bloqués
dans les pyrénées depuis mercredi
dernier
finalement coûté la vie à un jour morts
les cinq jeunes gens ont été redescendus
dans la vallée
ils sont soignés en ce moment en
revanche la corde et de secours qui
étaient partis à leur recherche et des
prises dans une avalanche et un gendarme
donc monsieur abadie 39 ans était
enseveli est décédé en début d'après
midi à l'hôpital de luchon enfin on
connaît maintenant le bilan définitif de
la catastrophe ferroviaire de bologne en
italie 50 morts une centaine de blessés
dont plusieurs dans un état grave ont
été retirés des carcasses des deux
wagons les deux trains qui ont déraillé
hier en raison d'un éboulement qui s'est
produit sur la voie parmi les rescapés
de cette catastrophe la plus grave en
italie depuis plus de 15 ans il y a
trente trois élèves d'une école de metz
accompagné de quatre enseignants qui
venait d'effectuer un séjour pédagogique
en grèce aucun d'entre eux n'a été
blessé
je vous rappelle maintenant les deux
grands résultats sportifs de la journée
en tennis c'est le mexicain ramirez qui
a remporté les internationaux de monte
carlo en battant le tchèque
smid votre recette et puis en cyclisme
c'est le champion du monde francesco
moser qui a gagné détaché le 76e
paris-roubaix l'une des classiques les
plus difficiles les plus éprouvants pour
les coureurs
et pour mieux s'en rendre compte jean
paul ollivier a choisi quelques passages
de champion dans ce que les spécialistes
appellent l'enfer du nord
salle un grand champion veut gagner
paris roubaix on la firme chaque année à
la veille de l'épreuve et à l'issue de
celle-ci au constat qu'il en est allé en
maison déplore néanmoins que beaucoup de
coureurs n'ai pu défendre leur chance
jusqu'au bout
en raison des nombreux incidents de
course et il en est encore ainsi ce soir
au terme d'une épreuve impitoyable en
raison de son parcours et des conditions
atmosphériques que ces derniers jours de
nombreux passages sur des normes pavé
souvent 10 juin vous l'avez vu des pavés
glissants en d'autres endroits la route
disparaissait souhaitèrent amener les
gens par la table et francesco moser l'a
attaqué sur ses routes de regarder son
rictus
pour espérer gagner voir ce bien classés
à roubaix il faut donc être formé
également accro bas et donc avoir la
chance de son côté
la véritable course comme d'habitude a
débuté à neuvy endroits où les coureurs
ont quitté la nationale pour s'engager
dans un chemin creux assez boueux ce
dimanche est en légère montée
moser avait pris la direction des
opérations alors qu'ils nous avaient
depuis trois kilomètres engagé sa longue
et courageuse pour sue voici freddy
maertens en plein effort cette année
encore les forçats de la route ont
mérité leur nom
yvette un tiercé c'est ta famille et à
longchamp le prix de la télévision
en tête alors il est ce tiercé leucate
et pof suivi de tommy ouvre le vin et
d'edouard french 12 résultats donc
quatre vingts et 12 rapporte vous voyez
pour 5 francs dans l'ordre 14400 79
francs et dans un ordre différent
1885 francs 50
événement de la semaine dans un tout
autre domaine le salon international du
prêt-à-porter féminin qui s'est terminée
mercredi dernier après avoir vu défiler
non seulement une escouade de bien jolis
mannequins mais également près de
cinquante mille acheteurs 94 collection
était présente et il n'était pas dénué
d'intérêt puisque 650 journalistes
étaient présents
faute avouée que l'une d'entre elles en
particulier avait de quoi éveiller chez
les plus blasés un regain de lyrisme
vous allez tout de suite comprendre
pourquoi
voici les modèles yves saint laurent je
mets donc un carré blanc un rectangle
blanc et je laisse parler d'image et
france roche yves saint laurent a fait
pour 1200 acheteurs des cinq continents
sa petite révolution annuel une
collection pour dames bien chauffé et
pour messieurs inflammable l'isna et qui
rate vêtus de probité candide de booth
les noirs ou les lustres en courant flou
et en transparent
j'y voyais et ne viennent pas du tout
pour marcher
r de velours doux et de rubans
et ces robes sont faites pour porter
pendant les longues soirées d'hiver
la chaleur ambiante déclenchée par elle
devrait suffire à dégeler l'atmosphère
d'ailleurs avec ses jeunes admiratrices
il faut atteindre pierre pour ne pas
prendre feu
en voyant ces statues ou les feuilles de
vigne sont remplacés par quelques toiles
dorées
les tailles obligatoire des bas noirs
c'est tellement dalli
bien restons calmes et sereins passons
maintenant à notre palmarès le hit
parade des chansons pas facile souvent
d'y figurer en bonne place
lorsqu'on est jeune inconnue et que de
plus l'on ne s'exprime points dans la
langue de shakespeare
l'anglais étant pratiquement le seul mot
de passe admis dans les discothèques un
petit peu à contre-courant de la mode
georges bigot a retrouvé renault bien
sûr ils ne représentent pas toute la
jeunesse qui est même un peu à part mais
déjà paraît-il le succès frappe à sa
porte plutôt s'accroche au guidon de sa
moto
nous ne sommes pas dans le tennessee ou
sur la côte ouest et dans les rues de
meudon au guidon du chopper renault
l'étoile de la zone il ne connaît pas
l'anglais il parle largo le verlan il
manie l'expression populaire avec
maestria et tout un public le comprend
après les années difficiles où il fut
magasinier plongeurs représentant les
métiers tout en continuant à gratter de
la guitare le voici aujourd'hui sur le
podium des hit parades mais c'est
toujours dans la même barak qu'il répète
avec ses codes le bar a commandé un jan
brewer procès le mois les doigts trompe
potel chabot
je parie t l'essentiel bien faire un
tour dans terrain vague qui s'apprend 20
jeux rigolos à grands coups de cette de
vélo j'te bénévole à la spa
laisse béton
et j'aime surtout les jeunes des milieux
urbains se reconnaissent en connaissent
leur langage et leur préoccupation
les faits divers quand ils sont tous
vécu ce que chante plus ou moins ils le
ressentent bien parce que je pense le
exprimé dans leur langage le samedi soir
les gens la maison des jeunes en
banlieue ils vont s'éclater à paris dans
une boîte de nuit
laurier personnes dans les maisons de
jeunes il semble les bistrots c'est la
seconde maison les dix mots c'est le
lieu de communication
privilégier pour les jeunes juniors
c'est là tout se passe c'est
l'accompagnement détruits on leur fait
brèves s'exprime comment font-ils les
autres jeunes pour s'en sortir ceux qui
ne sont pas chanteur aux champions de
football
le devance ils font ils font les
conneries qui meublent les pages des
faits divers des journaux ni vol libre
accueille 700 nuits d'istres malgré les
impératifs du show-business renault il
reviendra toujours dans ce bistrot ne
serait ce que pour chanter boris vian
on n'est pas là pour se faire piétiner
le voilà
on a trop mettre un point final à cette
actualité de ce dimanche la météo pour
demain
tant qu'on soleil et avec des nuages
passagers sur le nord les ardennes les
alpes
vent faible faiblissant en particulier
sur le languedoc et la vallée du rhône
des températures nocturnes basse avec
attention des gelées pour lever du jour
même dans les régions méditerranéennes
par contre la température se rompre en
hausse au cours de la journée
vous retrouverez je le pense avec
plaisir bernard ap vers 23h ce soir pour
la dernière édition du journal et je
vous souhaite particulièrement une très
belle soirée sur antenne 2